Transcriber: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Herkese merhablar!
80'li yıllarda doğdum, 90'lı yıllarda
çocukluğumu yaşadım.
Özellikle televizyon en yakın
arkadaşlarımdan biri oldu.
Onunla beraber inanılmaz
keyifli vakitler geçirdik.
Mesela, Pazar günleri
Sinema Kulübü'nün üyesiydim
ve Polis Akademisi en iyi hatırladığım
filmlerden bir tanesiydi.
Bunu dışında Saadettin Teksoy vardı.
Onunla beraber gönülden gönüle koşardık.
Tabii bir yandan da Siyaset Meydanı'nı
hiç unutamam.
Tartışmak nedir, fikir alışverişi
nedir, dinlemek nedir?
Onu öğrenmiştim aslında orada.
Ve tabii farklı keyifli
programlar da vardı.
Mesela Sabah Şekerleri...
Sabah Şekerleri'nde en ilginç
olan hatırladığım şey
faks makineleri ve o faks
ile gelen insanların
gönderdiği binlerce mesajlardır
ve orada isminiz geçiyorsa
inanılmaz mutlu oluyordunuz, çünkü
görünürlük ihtiyacı belki en temel
ihtiyaçlarımızdan bir tanesiydi.
Tabii bir yanda sadece televizyon yoktu,
televizyon dışında gazeteler,
dergiler de vardı
tanıştığım medya organlarıyla.
Mesela pazar günleri gazete günüydü,
o günün neredeyse yarısını
gazetenin tamamını
ve eklerini okumakla geçirirdim.
Özellikle son sayfasındaki
spor haberleri olsun,
ya da her seferinde
değişen ekleri olsun,
inanılmaz keyif aldığım zamanlardı.
Tabii benim medyayla ilişkim bu
zamanlarda böyle ilerlerken
medyanın geçmişi neye dayanıyordu?
Ona baktığım zamanda ta
insanlık kadar eski bir dünyadan
bahsettiğimizi görüyordum.
Mesela Mısırlılarla başlıyor
medyanın geçmişi,
papirüs adını verdikleri kâğıtlara
günlükler yazıyorlardı
ve yazdıkları günlükleri de
insanlarla paylaşıyorlardı.
Ve Papirüs'ün de aslında bugünkü
İngilizce kelime olan
"Paper"nin kökeni olduğunu öğrendim.
Onun dışında Romalılara gidiyordunuz,
Romalılar "Aktaduma" adını verdikleri
resmi gazeteler yayınlıyorlardı.
Bu yayınların hepsini tabletlere yazarak
o dönemdeki resmi görevlilerin
meydanlara toplanıp
insanlara o tabletlerdeki
yazıları okuyarak
Julius Caesar'ın ne yaptığını,
neyi paylaşmak istediğini,
hangi fetihlerde bulunduğunu anlatıyordu.
Ve ondan sonra da tabii yüzyıllar geçti.
Bu geçen yüzyıllar içerisinde
tabii ki insanlık hâli de
gelişmeye devam etti.
Ve Gutenberg ile karşılaştık.
Kendisi modern matbaanın
kurucularından biriydi.
Ve onun yarattığı yeni matbaa
ve yeni yayıncılık sebebiyle
insanoğlunun gelişimi çok daha
hızlanmaya başlamıştı.
Artık bilgi çok daha fazla üretilebiliyor.
Ve üretilen bilgi coğrafyalara
paylaşılabiliyordu, yayınlanabiliyordu.
Ve bu sayede de belki Avrupa'daki
rönesans ve reform hareketleri
Gutenberg'e çok şey borçluydu.
Tabii ki 19. yüzyıla kadar
matbaanın etkisini
görmeye başladık ve radyo icat edildi.
Devamında televizyon hayatlarımıza
girmeye başladı.
İşte televizyonla benim
tanışıklığımın hikayesi
aslında çok yıllar öncesine dayanıyordu.
2000'lere geldiği zaman
milenyum çağındaydık.
Ve ben de ilk defa aslında yeni medyanın
kökenini sağlayacak olan İnternet'le
tanışmaya başlamıştım.
İnternet'le tanışmam çok temel
ihtiyaçlardan kaynaklanıyordu.
Aslında o dönemlerden popüler
bazı mesajlaşma
uygulamaları vardı, Messenger gibi,
mIRC gibi sohbet platformları vardı.
Orada nicknamelerle sohbet odalarına dalıp
arkadaşlıklar elde ederdik, ama bir yandan
ICQ vardı, oradaki numaramızı
ezbere bilirdik adeta.
Evdeki numaramızı
bilmeyen çocuklar,
ICQ numarasını ezbere söyleyebilirlerdi.
Tabii, internet çok kolay ulaşılabilirmiş
gibi de değildi bu arada.
İnternet paketleri vardı, bu İnternet
paketlerinin en önemli özelliği
çok hızlı bir şekilde gitmesiydi.
Bu biten paketler bizi 146
numarasına bağımlı kılmıştı
ve devirdeki faturalarda yansıyan bir
şişkinlik meydana gelmişti.
Yani anlayacağınız internete girmek
de kolay bir şey değildi.
Tabii internet'le beraber
gelişen teknolojiler,
Yeni platformlar, yeni fikirleri
doğurmaya başlamıştı.
Ve ondan sonra doğan fikirler de
sosyal medyayı icat edecekti.
Peki sosyal medya noktasına gelmeden önce,
internetin tarihi bu kadar
eskilere dayanıyor muydu?
Hayır, 1971 yılında başlıyordu
ve 1989 yılında üç W'nun
hayatımıza girmesiyle beraber
internet toplumla tanışmaya başlıyordu.
Doksanlarda ilk blog yazısı yazılmıştı.
1996 yılında ClassMate adını
verdikleri bir sosyal ağ
ilk kez dünyaya doğmuştu.
Ve ondan on yıl sonra neredeyse
Facebook doğacak ve Facebook
sosyal medyanin aslında
isminin bulunmasına yardımcı olacak
en büyük platform olucaktı.
Tabii Facebook yoktu sadece
2000'lerde karşımıza çıkan.
Farklı farklı platformlar da vardı:
YouTube gibi, LinkedIn gibi,
Wikipedia gibi, bunların hepsi
2000'lerin ürünüydü.
Ve karşımıza bu platformları önce
sosyal ağ olarak çıkmaya başladı,
daha sonrasında birer medyaya
dönüşmeye başladılar.
Bugün Facebook dediğimiz mecrada
2 milyardan fazla insanın
kendi kanalı bulunuyor.
YouTube 1.5 milyar kişiye ulaşmış durumda.
Onun dışında diğer mecralar da milyonlarca
milyarlarca kişinin var olduğu,
yer aldığı bir dünyaya doğru gidiyor.
Peki burada biz neden buralarda
var olmaya başlamıştık,
bu kadar hızlı bir şekilde,
yoğun bir şekilde?
Bunun tabii ki
farklı bir ekosistemi vardı.
Şöyle düşünün, internet ilk
çıktığı zamanlarda
daha çok pasif olarak kullanıyorduk,
Daha çok sadece bilgiye ulaşıyor,
bilgiyi belki izleyebiliyorduk.
Ama internetin gelişmesiyle beraber
interaktif dünya karşımıza çıktı.
Biz bu Dünya'da, bu mecralarda
artık yorum yapabiliyor,
konuşabiliyor, paylaşabiliyor;
kendi mecralarımızda
kendi kanallarımızı yaratıp,
aynı televizyondaki kanallar gibi
bir yayın akışı sağlayabiliyorduk.
Twitter'da ayrı konuşuyor, Facebook'ta
başka şeyler paylaşıyor,
Instagram'da gezdiğimiz yerleri,
gördüğümüz şeylerin
havasını atıyorduk ve bu böyle
ilerlerken sosyal medya dünyası,
tabii ki benim buradaki
rolüm biraz farklıydı.
Sosyal medya dünyası içerisinde
profesyonel olarak yer alma
fırsatını elde etmiştim.
İlk sosyal medyanın konuşulduğu yıllarda,
profesyonel olarak bu
dünyaya giriş yapmış,
ajans kurmuş ve bu ajansı uluslararası
bir ortaklığa kadar taşımıştım.
Ve bunu yaptığım süreçte de
yüzlerce video, binlerce haber,
on binlerce içeriği
milyonlarca insana ulaştırma
fırsatını elde etmiştim.
Ve bu yolculukta sosyal
medya kullanıcılarının
nasıl davrandığını, nasıl hareket
ettiğini, nasıl bir iletişim kurduğunu,
kendi kanallarını nasıl
yönetme motivasyonları
olduğunu birebir gözlemlemiştim.
Evinize giren bir ürünün neden alındığını,
ya da nasıl bir motivasyonla siz
o ürünle iletişim kurduğunuzun
yollarını sosyal medya üzerinden
yaratmaya başlamıştım.
İşte bu noktada karşıma inanılmaz
sorular çıkmaya başlamıştı
ve bu soruları da Türkiye'deki
Bilişim Vakfı gibi çeşitli
platformlarda da
"Yeni medya nereye gidiyor?",
"Sosyal medya insanları
nasıl değiştirecek?"
"O kadar hızlı bir değişim,
o kadar hızlı bir dönüşüm var ki
karşımıza neler çıkmaya başlayacak?"
Bu sorularla kendimi bulmaya başlamıştım.
Ve o sorularda şunu görüyordum:
Mesela otorite değişmeye başlıyordu.
Geleneksel medyanın daha önceki otoritesi,
yani bir medyaya siz sahipseniz,
insanları, yığınları,
etkileyebiliyorken artık
bu sosyal medya sayesinde
insanlar yarattığı kararlarla
binlere, on binlere
medya üzerinden değil, geleneksel
medya üzerinden değil,
Yeni Medya üzerinden ulaşabiliyordu.
Yani otorite el değiştirmeye başlıyordu.
Bu değişen otoritenin en önemli
örneklerini şöyle verebiliriz:
Mesela Arap malları vardır,
Orta Doğu'yu çok iyi,
çok farklı bir noktada etkileyen...
Onun dışında Amerika'daki seçimler vardır,
Şu anda seçimlerin sosyal medyada
nasıl etkisi olduğu konuşuluyor,
nasıl burada hangi başkanın hangi
sosyal medya kampanyalarıyla kazandığı
tartışılıyorken; ama bir yandan da,
bunun başka bir perspektifinde de
şöyle bir sosyal medyayla karşılaştım:
Facebook vardı, Google vardı,
ve bu iki mecra
otoritenin belki kontrolüne inanmıştı ama
yüzde doksan bir payla tekele sahipti.
Yani aslında bu mecralar
da yarın öbür gün,
sizi orada var etmedikleri sürece
var olamayacağınız
bambaşka tekellere dönüşüyordu.
Ve bu tip risklerle hep beraber
karşılaşmaya başlayacağımız
bir dünyaya doğru gidiyorduk.
Buradaki rekabet farklı farklı sonuçlarla
karışımıza çıkıyordu,
YouTube diyordu ki,
"Artık İnternetin olmadığı ortamlarda
da beni izleyebilirsin."
Facebook diyordu ki,
"Artık ben de spor kanallarının
yayın haklarını satın alıyorum,
Artık Facebook'tan da televizyonu
takip eder gibi,
maçları takip edebilirsin." dediğimiz
bir dünyaya doğru gidiyorduk.
Ve bu dünyada, bu mecralarda
kanal sahipleri,
birer aslında farklı bir noktaya
gidiyorlardı
ama bunun farkında değillerdi.
Ve bu soruyu sorduğum zamanda,
en sonunda lise zamanlarımda tanıştığım
ünlü psikoloji profesörü
Maslow aklıma gelmişti.
Ve Maslow'a baktığım zaman kendisi
bir fiziksel ihtiyaçlar
piramidi tezi atmıştı.
Ve attığını tezde de öncelikle diyordu ki
'İnsanlar kendi fiziksel ihtiyaçlarını;
açlık, susuzluk gibi
ihtiyaçlarını karşılamalı.
Daha sonrasında güvenlik
ihtiyaçları geliyordu.
Bunun devamında sevgiyi,
şefkati bulma noktasında
ihtiyaçlarını tatmin edip
devamında ancak
saygınlığa ulaşabiliyorlardı.
Ve en sonunda da bunların
hepsini başarabilen,
bunlardan tamamıyla tatmin olan insanlar
kendini gerçekleştirebiliyorlardı.
Ve bu tabloyu gördüğüm zaman,
Sosyal medyadaki bütün o
kullanıcıların kendi kanallarını
yönetmeye çalışan insanların
motivasyonlarını
yan yana koymaya başladım
ve karşıma başka bir piramit çıktı.
Bu çıkan piramit, şöyle söyleyeyim,
en altta yine fiziksel
ihtiyaçlarla başlıyordu.
Evet, ben belki 90’lı yıllardan
2000’lere kadar
internete girmek için
çok zorlanmıştım.
Eve bilgisayar almak, internete
ulaşmak çok zordu.
Ama artık fiziksel ihtiyaçlar anlamında
internete bağlı kalmak, telefona
ulaşmak, bilgisayara ulaşmak,
bir internet bağlantı
noktasının içerisinde olmak,
en önemli, en basit ihtiyaçlar
hâline gelmişti.
Sonrasında güvenlik ihtiyaçlarımız
ortaya çıkmaya başladı.
Çünkü bu ağa girdikten sonra bilgimizin,
güvenliğimizin sağlanması
insanlarla rahatlıkla
iletişim kurabileceğimiz
platformların oluşturulması gerekiyordu.
Bunu sağlayan kişiler işte
sosyal ağlara girmeye başladı.
O ağlar içerisinde kendi kanallarını,
profillerini yaratıp
bu profiller üzerinden
arkadaşlarını bulmak,
eski okul arkadaşlarıyla tanışmak,
belki de flört etmek için o sevgi,
şefkat ihtiyaçlarını
karşılamaya başlamıştı.
Aynı Maslow’un piramidinde olduğu gibi,
onun üstünde artık bu ağlar
medyaya dönüştüğü için, dönüşen medyada
"Acaba benim kanalım izleniyor mu?"
"Benim paylaştığım fotoğraf
beğeni alıyor mu?"
ya da "Koyduğum videoya karşı insanlar
benim kanalıma abone oluyor mu?"
gibi daha saygınlık, daha prestij odaklı
ihtiyaçlar çıkmaya başlamıştı ki,
Piramit'in en son
noktasına ulaşan kişiler,
yani bugün çok popüler dediğimiz
o fenomenler ortaya çıkmıştı.
Ve bu fenomenler de gerçekten
şu anda milyonların arasından
ancak bir elin parmakları sayısında
çıkan insanlara dönüşmüştü.
Peki, bu insanlar çok farklı
şeyler mi yapıyordu?
Buradaki kişilerden çok mu
farklı profillere sahipti?
Hayır, değil.
Bir tanesi mesela Japonya’da
evimi nasıl iyi düzenleyebilirim,
nasıl evimi aktif ve düzenli
bir şekilde kullanabilirim
noktasında taktikler verdiği bir kanalla
binlere, on binlere ulaşmıştı.
Başka bir tanesi çok iyi pasta
yapıyordu, kek yapıyordu
ve bunu yaparken çok keyif alıyordu
ve günümüz trendleri üzerinde gidip
bir sinema karakterini,
bir animasyon karakterini
canlandırdığı keklerle, pastalarla
bunları insanlara nasıl
yapabileceklerini gösterdi.
Ve bu kişi de yine milyonlarca
kişinin izlediği bir kanal yaratmıştı.
Ve şöyle düşünün,
bugün hangi televizyon kanalı
milyonlarca kez izleniyor?
Ne kadar sayabilirsiniz?
Böyle milyonlarca, milyarca
izlenmiş kanalları...
Ancak sosyal medya sayesinde
bu şekilde platformlar,
yeni yeni kanallar türemeye başlamıştı.
Ve hepsininde kendi yayın akışları vardı.
Peki, bu Piramit'in üst noktasına
çıkan kişileri biliyoruz,
ama altında olan milyonlar
ve az önce saydığım
milyarlar olarak bu devinimde,
bu mücadelede, burada ki
iletişim dünyamızda
biz nelerle karşı karşıya kalıyoruz?
Ona baktığımız zamanda gerçekten
tablonun hem iyi tarafını görüyoruz,
hem de farklı bir negatif
tarafını görebiliyoruz.
Şöyle düşünelim,
bir kere sosyal medyada
siz kanallarınızı var ettikten sonra,
bu fenomenler nasıl fenomen oluyor?
Sizlerin verdiği bu beğenilerle,
yaptığınız videoları paylaşmanızla,
ya da onların kanalına abone olmanızla.
Yani sizler aslında birer
sosyal medya için
birer jüri hâline gelmeye başladınız.
Yani ayırdığınız vakit doğrultusunda
jürilik görevide yapıyorsunuz.
Aslında sadece eskiden olduğu gibi
o medyayı tüketen değil,
aynı zamanda üreticileri de
olmaya başladınız.
Ve ürettiğiniz noktada bu platformlar
sizin sayenizde aslında
var olmaya başladı.
Bugün Facebook eğer yılda
10 milyon dolardan
fazla kâr elde ediyorsa
bunda sizlerin de payı var.
Peki, hiç bir kuruş kazandınız
mı bu zamana kadar?
Hayır!
Çünkü siz de "Artık bu saatten sonra
gelir elde edebilir miyiz?",
"Acaba sosyal medyada ne yaparsak
buradan ticari dönüş elde edebiliriz?"
bunu sorgulamaya başladınız.
Ama onun dışında da paylaştığınız
her şeyden de sorumlusunuz.
Biliyorsunuz artık yakınınızdaki
bir arkadaşınız
attığı bir Twitter postu yüzünden
işinden çıkartılabilir.
Ya da haberlerde okuyorsunuz,
yazdığı bir blog yazısı yüzünden
mahkemelere çıkmış
ve davalara konu olmuş konulara var.
Yani sizin bu sosyal medya kullanırken
aynı zamanda da sorumluluklarınızı da
taşıyorsunuz gerçek hayatla ilgili.
Hatta bazı devletler bununla ilgili
sosyal güvenlik çalışmalarında
sosyal medya puanlamaları
çıkarmaya başlıyorlar.
Mesela Çin, bunu yapmaya başlıyor.
Tabii aynı zamanda
bu sosyal medya dünyasında
sizden birer bir an içerinde
yıldız olabilirsiniz,
bir an içerisinde lince
de uğrayabilirsiniz.
Çeşitli troller var artık.
Troll grupları var.
Bu troll gruplarının eline
geçtiğiniz takdirde,
çok farklı şekilde imajınız,
bütün algınız ve farklı kişilerin
sizlerle ilgili algısı değişebilir.
Bu tip risklerle karşı karşıya olduğunuz
bir dünyadan bahsediyoruz.
Bunun şu an çok farkında değiliz.
Çünkü hep uzağımızdaki,
dışarımızdaki kişilerle bunlar
karşılaşmaya başladı.
Ama birileri bunun
üzerinde çalışmaya
başladılar bile.
Nasıl başladılar,
biliyor musunuz?
Şöyle söyleyeyim,
Bugün adını Bit Clean dediğimiz, Steam
dediğimiz, Nexus dediğimiz
yeni yeni platformlar çıkmaya başladı.
Bu platformların ortak özelliği şuydu:
Sosyal medya, kanalları üretenler
ve onların yarattığı içerikler sayesinde
aslında bugün vardı
ve bu kadar güçlüydü.
Peki, bunların haklarını, yani
kullanıcıların haklarını
neden savunmuyoruz?
Neden içerik üreten ve o içeriğin
en iyi olduğuna karar veren kişiler
bundan herhangi bir ödül,
herhangi bir gelir elde etmiyor?
Ya da sizin paylaştığınız içerikler
ve orada verdiğiniz bilgiler,
kimliğinizle ilgili bilgiler olsun,
bütün oradaki yaptığınız
davranışlar olsun,
beğendiğiniz markalar olsun,
bunlarla ilgili bütün bilgileri
sizin adınıza birileri
başkalarına satmaya başladı.
Peki, bunu size soruyor mu?
Ya da sorduğunu siz anlıyor musunuz?
Bunu sorgulayan platformlar
çıkmaya başladı.
Ya da Google üzerinde yaptığınız
bütün aramalarda, yarattığınız
bütün davranış şekillerinde sizin adınıza
birileri bu davranışları başka
birilerine satıyorsa?
Peki sizin bundan ne kadar
haberiniz oluyor?
Ya da buradan en ufak bir geri dönüş
elde edebiliyor musunuz?
İşte bunu sorgulayan platformlar
artmaya başladı.
Bugün bunların adını bilmiyoruz,
ama yarın bu platformların
fikirleri duyulunca,
bundan heyecan duymaya,
bu sefer kendi bulunduğunuz kanalı
sorgulamaya başlayacağız.
Mesela, Mark Zuckerberg
bunu yapmaya başladı.
Nasıl yapmaya başladı biliyor musunuz?
Her sene bir hedefini,
bir dileğini söylerdi.
Mesela derdi ki: Çince öğrenmek.
Başka bir yıl derdi ki:
Bu sene her gün kravat giyeceğim,
kravat takacağım.
Bu sene ne dedi biliyor musunuz?
“Facebook’u düzelteceğim,
Facebook’da değiştirmem
gereken yerler var,
bunlar üzerinde çalışacağım” dedi.
Bunun sebebi işte arka tarafta
bu kanal sahiplerinin asıl beklentileri,
yeni yeni inovatif teknolojilerle
ortaya çıkan yeni platformların
gücü ve güçlenişi.
Bunların arkasında bu vardı.
Çünkü on milyar dolarlık bir
pastayı kaybetmek,
ya da oradaki kişileri kaybetmek,
çok büyük bir risk taşıyordu.
Belki bugün Arap Baharı diyoruz,
Belki yarın Facebook Baharı diye
bir oluşum çıkacak ve bu Facebook’u
çok ciddi bir şekilde
etkileyebilecekti.
Keza devletler de bunlarla ilgili
çalışmalara başladı.
Mesela Avrupa Birliği,
bununla ilgili güvenli veri
deflasyonu özellikli
çeşitli kanallar yayınlamaya başladı.
Almanya Facebook kanalları adını verdiği
sadece nefret söylemlerini yasaklamak
üzere çıkardığı kanunlar var.
Ona göre cezalar vermeye başladılar.
Ve gördüğünüz gibi,
aslında başkaları bizim
kanallarımızla ilgili
birçok insiyatif sahibi,
birçok kurallar koymaya başlıyor.
Peki, bundan bu saatten sonra,
bugünden sonra kanalımızla ilgili
neleri değiştirmemiz lazım?
Neleri sorgulamamız lazım?
İşte bu noktada bazı taktikler
vermek istiyorum.
Şöyle düşünün:
Şu anda hepinizin belli yerlerde
belli üyelikleriniz var.
Ve orada aynı televizyon gibi
çeşitli yayınlar sağlıyorsunuz.
Ve sağladığınız yayınlarda da,
insanları etkilemeye, ikna etmeye,
yeri geliyor beğenilmeye çalışıyorsunuz.
İşte o noktada hangi mecrada
neden öyle bir kanal açtınız?
Bunu çok iyi bir şekilde
sorgulamanız lazım.
O kanalda neden öyle bir
iletişim yapıyorsunuz?
Bunu çok iyi bir şekilde
artık planlamanız gerekiyor.
Ve yaptığınız iletişim
ve yaptığınız her türlü paylaşım için
vakit ayırıyorsunuz.
Sizin vaktiniz her türlü
çok değerli bir vakit.
Peki bu vakit karşılığında doğru
bir geri dönüş alabiliyor musunuz?
Yani kanalınızın reytingini
hiç ölçüyor musunuz?
Oraya ayırdığınız vakite
karşılık aldığınız
geri dönüşler birbirine uyuyor mu?
Peki, kanalınızla ilgili
güvenlik ayarlarını
hiç kontrol ettiniz mi?
Hangi bilgileriniz başkalarına satılıyor?
Ya da başka birilerinin
ulaşımına katkı sağlıyor?
Hiç bunu düşündünüz mü?
İşte bu noktada yarattığımız
bütün iletişim çalışmalarında
sorumlu olduğumuz,
evet belki biliyoruz, belki hissediyoruz.
Peki, beş yıl sonra da aynı şekilde
bugün paylaştıklarımızın
arkasında durabilecek miyiz?
İşte bu tip soruları kendimize sorup
kanalımızı gerçekten en iyi
şekilde yönetmek için
doğru taktikler, doğru stratejiler
geliştirmem gerekiyor.
Evet, belki bugün için
bunları yapmak çok basit gelebilir
ama bu medyanın
sosyal medyanın mevcut
medyayı dönüştürdüğü,
geliştirdiği ve bizim anlamamızın
ve anlamlaştırmamızın zorlaştığı dünyada
ve kurallarında her gün değiştiği dünyada
bunu belki her gün sorgulamamız gerekecek.
O yüzden de size en son şunu
söylemek istiyorum,
90’larda ünlü bir anchorman'in sözü vardı:
“Her nerede yaşıyor ya da
yaşatılıyorsanız”.
Sizler de sosyal medyada kanalınıza
sahip çıkın diyorum.
Teşekkürler.